these are the sights and sounds of war
in Ukraine these the realities of combat
in a country invaded by its largest
neighbor
and yet in Sydney France or Eastern
Front we are given a glimpse of far more
for in this film we see the other
aspects of life since the Russian
invasion from the happiest moments with
family and friends to the times of
greatest Danger
the directors of the film set out to
Chronicle close up this nation's fight
for survival as a message it's like how
can everything change in one second uh
like all your friends who was like
colleagues who uh someone some guy work
on color correction some you know
everyone on front line the situation in
Ukraine is a Transcendent theme at this
year's berlinala several of the films
here deal with it directly with the aim
to keep it at the Forefront of people's
minds
certainly that's the case for the
artistic director of this year's
Festival this film tried to make
something different trying of course to
move our conscience and to make us be
more aware of all these matters but at
the same time to give an Insight from a
very personal point of view
with the film in Ukraine we see what
many civilians there have found
themselves doing learning how to use an
automatic rifle
the nervous smiles and laughter during
the lessons are a distraction from the
question of how effective these novice
soldiers might be in real fighting
in some areas destroyed tanks provide an
impromptu play thing for the younger
generation
yeah
foreign
while the more traditional playgrounds
now Nestle between bombed buildings
some areas are out of bounds entirely
here the Happy wailing of infants has
given way to the high frequency whale of
the mine detector
a reminder that in the war in Ukraine
even children are targets
Donna Kane Al Jazeera Berlin